[Music]
did you guys see that tweet that Jake
Paul tweeted and then it went viral
because people were hating on him for
tweeting this tweet yes education no
it's about mental health it is so this
is what his face looks like in case you
forgot we try to forget it but he's
trying to move into doing what I'm doing
pretty much up Lunchables even knowing
he could be a really cool guy but he
just has a bunch of a face for me it's
not the face I think it's the the the
aura good attitude okay so this is your
Tariq's really thin true this is the
tweety tweety remember yeah you want to
read it
remember anxiety is created by you
sometimes you gotta let life play out
and remind yourself to be happy and that
the answers will come chill your mind
out go for a walk talk to a friend into
a space what's wrong with that though
that part that's harmful mark is the
reaction that how I get rid of my
anxiety like you're just nuts okay well
is that what he said he didn't tell you
how to get rid of exactly yeah yeah
she's saying it's all in your head it's
it's pretty much it's invalidating
people's anxiety the way he worded this
the method the first statement is
remember anxieties created by you I
can't be taken out of context yes I did
picture he was I trying to coach the
world I pictured as if you know most
people from Twitter Instagram they're
just talking about themselves so I just
thought he was talking about how he
likes to get rid of it shoulda said it
that way yeah because it's like if you
really dissect this and you see the
words I keep decided to choose yeah he's
trying to get into the coaching space I
see he has a program out right now that
basically is the same exact thing that I
said is that the school system sucks and
that people aren't learned to they're
not taught to be successful in the real
effective way so he has something out
there which mine is free by the way [ __ ]
you Jake Paul because you are charging
people who's charging 20 bucks a month
that's pretty reasonable raise is the
charging completely for free dessert
then you are charging why you hate money
charging for free I don't know if I want
to have a coach who's not interested in
making money
yeah there's value in Jay Paul's device
Joe I don't think that's you in it to
charge people company called the jig
Paulie and Academy you know what I love
about you know what I love about this
kind of [ __ ] though is that you can
charge like you can start somebody like
a grand Rite yeah and you're like I am
charging you a grand because I want you
to prove that you're gonna take this
seriously it works it does but you know
it works on me so check this out when I
had a gym membership for 20 bucks a
month
I never went but when I had a gym
membership for 700 bucks for three years
and Equinox or what no it's actually a
24 hour fitness month
no no $700 right you pay $700 upfront
three years and for a lifetime it's 50
bucks for the whole entire year that's
actually what got me to go I need to go
to the gym everyday to get my money's
worth
oh yeah yes that's when I [ __ ]
changed my body from being 120 pounds to
160 but a lot of people could just go I
have a gym membership I'm not gonna
waste his money I'll just go to the gym
right but that's not how it works
actually I get that I'm the same way if
I'm like it if I was paying more I'd be
like I need to make this work yes there
is consumer psychology so it depends of
course yeah of course some people need
to make the huge commitment to go you
know what this is gonna motivate me and
make me accountable to doing what I
happy but it's also a sales tactic it's
funny it is but I see both sides okay
but but but not by the way but
unfortunately not my [ __ ] gym because
everybody goes goddamn full all the
machines are [ __ ] you have to get
there at 5:30 in the morning
what's that so it's a membership that
you have and then you could go to all
these different gyms and like you can do
kickboxing or yoga or cycling or you
could go to different gyms for weight
training and all this other stuff it's
super cool I love it and I use it on
like Groupon I wish torts eat what I
would pay for is the 24 hour fitness
thing where the trainer comes up to guy
he taps him he's like hey get the [ __ ]
up this guy's gonna come in here pays
more than you that would be sick dude
that would be sick buy that that would
be very good is it I don't know
Equinox she goes Equinox and she loves
it hardest tight I still haven't even
snow there so she's guest she's brought
me on with a Guest Pass because I'm like
I keep it I got my 24-hour fitness I'm
good with that
yeah but um she goes in and she also
feels like so I thought my 25 fitness
was [ __ ] clean [ __ ] nice she went
into my 24 from her to her gym in Canada
I was like yo your gym is so gross right
so she goes to Equinox cuz it's mad
clean because you know it's more
expensive and she goes to the classes
they provide but also she feels like she
gets hit on less at Equinox
and it's a different demographic yeah
yeah you know so Arclight versus AMC
yeah that dude that's a big jump and
it's just for the one or two dollars
extra you kind of weed out the theater
talker you rid of the where riffraff
those who don't know about the ArcLight
don't look it up you're fine stay out of
my [ __ ] you could choose your seat
once you start going to a movie theater
where you like choose your seats and you
were planning and [ __ ] you will never go
back to a regular a theater you know how
sick is it that you can now apply a
drink at the ArcLight and walk it into
any theater oh you know yeah it used to
be you had to wait for the rated-r movie
to play and you could only go in a rated
R movie yeah but now you can walk them
into Pixar's and [ __ ] dude there's down
people getting [ __ ] up oh well I've
been going to one of these dynein AMC's
by my house where it's like it's a hole
as meal you know it's better I pick I
have you know you get lobster roll and a
Frappuccino and a blanket I pick is six
yeah trouble so I thought the I pick was
a movie theater by the Apple company
should have been opportunity can you
believe they don't call it a i watch by
the way they should call it I was not I
know I hate it because I call it I watch
yeah give me a [ __ ] break
but people call it I want what we do
I've never called the Night Watch in my
life
anyways tell me about this please okay
so the whole thing remember we're
talking about Jake Paul and anxiety oh
so they are saying that he pretty much
invalidated everyone's anxiety disorder
and just the way she worded it but
people like actual psychologists and
behavioral people
saying like okay he's not completely
wrong like yes it does
technically come from you because it's
not caused by other things it is
internally
yeah triggered yeah and then there's
also like biological issues like
nutrition deficiencies or hormonal
imbalances or societal problems like
sexism and racism that could be
contributing to anxiety so did he get
the last laugh cuz he's like haha I'm
right he did I mean I'm sure a lot of
people signed up and he's making last
one actually he did because he tweeted
this out and it says everyone clowning
might tweet but it's now spreading more
awareness about anxiety which I didn't
even know was a thing till I was 18 but
had it my whole life and never knew how
to deal with it if you think you have it
or want to deal with it try reading this
and it's a link to health line that says
how to cope with anxiety 11 simple ways
well I would have been better if you
would have put that out first cuz now
he's trying to like the first one people
hate on his ass cuz he's trying to come
out like someone that took on authority
figure in the [ __ ] space so people
are like [ __ ] you you can before he
tweeted out the anxiety thing he was
retweeting a lot of like suicide hotline
stuff and or actually he yeah he
retweeted that and then like other
mental health things and also this stuff
that Joe was talking about where you can
like learn how to how to live your life
on your terms to achieve your dreams
goals and have financial freedom for his
whole god I prefer this than him talk
about blue shoe is it does he talk about
blue - you don't know blue chip
what's blue chip a blue chip oh oh blue
- hey if you want to last longer and go
extra rounds ah new - docking on that
one
you got your parking lots of are blue -
no oh [ __ ] well blue - calm it's a
different demo yeah I guess so maybe our
demo
they don't need dick pills mucho Mucho
contains already horny they get hard
I mean well my you know my fans are
older so blue
contains the same problem no he's a good
sport its dick pills what we not
specific pills but yes you know what
they should do is make dick pizza dad
[ __ ] I'd eat that then you eat those
digs bro no no dick pizzas like yo week
when we put the pills in the pizza
you're officially hooked up no but the
pills aren't bad they're true they're
tasty you like it yeah they're cool
they're cool like you know but I thought
you're a horny ass guy I am alone yes
guy but also a slice be harder I popped
him on the honeymoon just cuz you know I
am older you know I'm saying like I papa
change over the years
listen guys I'll tell you right now all
this [ __ ] about oh I can't get hard
that's all in your head man hey take a
[ __ ] walk
it's me about my dick outside there's no
such thing as a reptile dysfunction i'm
steve green and i mean it no but for
real some truth today well how much is
it gonna cost me to coach me $20 a month
but we can talk rates come down that
repart may be different free but i don't
pay that to consume the services okay I
don't know exactly why I just have more
important products that are for sale
yeah but then all the basics I teach for
free I do anything that involves
hardening dicks around Bart no offense
I'm gonna discriminate against you and
you only that's actually the best person
to partner up with with the history that
you guys have I know that's what I'm
afraid of
yeah here's the one bar to check his
dick size no I'll be checking my own
dick sighs what about hardness are we
talking about that yeah yeah he's pretty
hard but I feel like here's the thing
like because like you know when you get
older it's like sometimes like you might
look like after your first bus you're
like I'm cool for the day but like the
the pills are like you know you're good
to go extra rounds and [ __ ] quicker than
what you would normally because we have
[ __ ] to do Lieut blue chalk on flash no
chaser for 20% off but if I don't want
to put the last part in because it's so
long as you can't you send that Belkin
you can pay the full oh yeah but
discount I just said 24 have a theory
about why we bust lesson whatever when
you get older is because one the stress
part and two you're busier because when
you're younger you have all the time of
the [ __ ] world to jack off 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
times an hour yeah yeah you you can just
bust marathon you [ __ ] take a nap to
recharge just so you could jack off
again right but then like you eat
carrots just to just to drag out for you
just to Jack just to [ __ ] not again
you've got a Java juice yeah in a
[ __ ] green smoothie just so you can
have the energy you take a hot bath and
tal your dick to relax it so you can
jack off study porn so that you can jack
off and you yeah yes you already like
keep other future jackoff material tabs
ready for later on a couple hours when
you're ready to go but when you're busy
and you're older you don't have that
time you're like do I jack off now or do
I sleep for hours and you're just sleepy
yeah you know I'm not a sleepy man I
only need five hours of sleep the same
but but after the night you're like okay
I'm fine would ya I wasn't that forget
it yeah but not your wood although wood
is opposite that shit's [ __ ] baby mole
going to bed I'm so glad I'm so glad
that I don't just like randomly not
myself because I could fall asleep while
driving
Wow think about that Buster if Nicky
gives you road head and you bust you
might
those off as soon as you go right
[Music]